garde-le pour
toi sur la pointe, tu les vois sur le
ouais je les ai je les ai il y en a
sur la colline et d'autres sur la colline en bas
ouais j'en ai juste là, ils
courent
déjà ouais
sombre et ceux du haut sont  ne bouge pas
alors lève la caméra, ok, il y a une
petite colline et ils ne bougent pas,
ils restent juste là à traîner
ouais
si vous pouvez voir l'eau derrière, ça pourrait
être sympa ouais, je pense qu'elle apparaîtra en
vue en venant pour le  de la glace derrière eux je
pense qu'on va continuer à venir on
verra peut-être
le
joli avec ce rocher à l'
arrière là on y
va c'est cool c'est encore plus beau que l'
autre oups on disparaît d'
ici redescends un peu
vers l'autre lot, le
lot inférieur, ils
courent
juste au sommet de la colline, ok,
ils sont arrivés ici dans les rochers dans le rocher, ok, je les ai perdus là-bas, ils montent
du
B non perdu ou peut-être qu'ils sont là-haut
merde, St enregistre depuis
les trouver en bas, ceux de
droite ont des bébés avec
eux, celui-ci est complètement flou,
ok
ouais, où sont ceux au sommet de
tout le ciel, donc il peut y avoir un vol perdu,
oh, à
droite  petit
cran, il
y a ceux au sommet de la colline,
ils semblent être plus
stables, pouvons-nous simplement ralentir lent, ralentir
jusqu'à environ 20 nœuds 25
nœuds peut-être descendre, allez vers eux et
descendez un peu plus bas pour que nous nous
approchions d'eux  hors de vue pour
qu'ils ne nous voient pas jusqu'à la dernière
minute
pouvons-nous les envoyer pour qu'ils franchissent le
sommet de la colline, puis se rapprochent d'
eux puis montons au-dessus de la colline
pour que nous les voyions quand beaucoup  plus près, je ne les
vois pas
non, nous les approchons pour nous
rapprocher de leur champ de
vision ouais
CL au-dessus du non non non non non d'accord, ce que je
veux faire, c'est commencer bas, à une
altitude inférieure à celle des animaux.
puis montons au-dessus de la colline pour
les voir afin que nous puissions arrêter l'
enregistrement, nous pourrons nous rapprocher
Concentrez-vous
oui, c'était une belle photo, il
peut nous faire la même chose en venant de ce
côté de la colline avec  l'avantage du
courant ascendant pour avec ce côté ouais fenêtre H
ok dans quel sens est euh
ouais
tu veux les voir dans le ciel et
après euh ouais ils s'en vont, qu'allons-nous
faire
ici pour les plus bas
L ceux-là certains vont  pour avoir le
ils se rassemblent tous ouais ils se
rassemblent tous
nous nous rapprochons d'eux
maintenant à
propos de ceux d'en bas, ceux-là sont
ceux qui étaient
là, ceux là
qui regroupent celui du haut
ouais non d'accord non non  ceux du milieu, ceux du
milieu À l'extérieur du milieu, il
parle de ceux du milieu
ouais, désolé, je me suis
trompé, je pense que vous pouvez faire dans le même plan
ceux du bas et ceux du milieu, le
même cercle autour du
groupe du bas, puis arriver à ceux du milieu.
comme dans le même plan
ok
euh le groupe du haut
comme
pan autre ouais trop loin pour faire un panoramique
mais l'autre groupe c'est bon sang, sont-ils
là
ouais nous essayons juste de nous rapprocher de ce
groupe du milieu voici celui-ci ici ouais
ouais celui qui est euh  à 13h00
il ne saute pas de la
falaise près
de
nous à la
seconde où ils vont rejoindre l'
autre on a un gros un grand groupe soit
facile à
filmer oh ils sont tous ouais ils y
vont tous  dans le même groupe, ok, ils se
réunissent ouais,
ok, ils vont former un grand groupe,
en fait, ce sera B pour filer,
ils sont tous
ensemble, ils traversent un fossé
là-bas,
ouais, rapproche-toi de ce grand groupe
maintenant, bébé, zoome et ouais  Je suis j'ai complètement
zoomé ouais je suis Tel
maintenant Clos c'est cool
oui les
garçons,
nous allons un peu plus bas, un peu plus bas,
venant ici si nous pouvons
anticiper, qu'en pensez-vous, l'
option Darthy ici, je pense que nous devrions euh
essayer de prendre une photo  quand ils ne
bougent pas, arrêtons d'enregistrer pour nous, pouvons-
nous
maintenant vérifier l'estimation à la correction de W
Bay à
peut-être faire un coup de cheville wi oh ici,
ils
ok
vérifient
et ils courent
ouais ok je suppose que ça
suffit ok euh j'ai  un petit point
au milieu de l'objectif ici euh arrête de tout
enregistrer
donc tu veux faire je fais le tu es là
dans une
minute ok juste en
ccle
nous
ici
ouais j'oublie
ça
ambitieux oh on pourrait pers si on veut
tu voles un peu plus lentement dans le
cercle plus lentement dans le ccle oui s'il te plaît
ouais
ok concentre-toi
bien
oui
657 6,5 po
r
ok ouais finis ouais
finis fais que tout le monde arrête ça ok allons-
y I